Es geht und es ist nötig landwirtschaft ohne tiere statt
massentierhaltung und mega stellen also bauernhöfe die komplett dir frei sind erste projekte zeigen jetzt tatsächlich
erfolgen wie das funktioniert und ob das tatsächlich eine lösung für eine gesunde und
Zukunftsfähige ernährung ist jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Massentierhaltung mit mega stellen tiertransporten und oft
unkontrollierter antibiotika vergabe hat nichts mit dem bauernhof in öl zu tun dass manche vielleicht noch
So, im kopf haben von wegen glückliche kühe und einer großen grünen wiese und hühnern die
Im dreck scharen um mal eben nach lust und laune ein ei legen stattdessen
masthähnchen die zu zehntausenden in großen allen gestopft werden
Schweine die in ihrem ganzen leben kein tageslicht gesehen haben und kühe mit entzündeten heute an allesamt voll gestopft mit
Antibiotika so schreibt die heinrich böll stiftung in ihrem fleisch atlas von
2016 zitat die massentierhaltung
Auf engstem raum wirkt sich negativ auf die tiere aber auch auf die umwelt aus so tragen gewaltige mengen an gülle und der ammonit
ausstoß der anlagen dazu beiden biotope grundwasser seen flüsse und
küstengewässer permanent mit nitrat zu übertönen die landwirtschaft ist wirklich zu einem großen
umweltverschmutzer geworden und das ist wirklich pervers schlimm genug doch das ganze hat zudem auch noch
weitreichende folgen für das klima und auch für uns die verbraucher die organisation foodwatch
Hat dazu einige studien analysiert und das ergebnis ist schlimm jedes vierte tierischen produkt stammt von einem
kranken tier und das sind dann
Am ende natürlich produkte die für uns nicht gesund sind doch die massentierhaltung ist ein riesiges geschäft um bei der produktion für den weltweiten export
mithalten zu können haben sich die meisten landwirte inzwischen auf eine einzige tierart
spezialisieren einige wenige betriebe wachsen rasant während im letzten jahrzehnt viele bauernhöfe die tierhaltung aufgegeben haben das paradoxe daran
Nach rechnung der heinrich böll stiftung hat die bundesweite fleischproduktion dennoch um etwa die hälfte zugenommen
Trotzdem steigt auch der anteil der vegetarier in deutschland laut der statista gmbh gibt es im jahr
2017 in der deutschsprachigen bevölkerung ab 14 jahren rund 5,7 millionen personen die sich selbst als vegetarier bezeichnen würden bzw
personen die weitgehend auf fleisch verzichten 2013 waren es noch 5,3 millionen menschen die
interessenvertretung für vegetarier und veganer webo geht sogar von rund acht millionen vegetarier in deutschland aus das sind etwa 10
der bevölkerung laut einer befragung eines
marktforschungsinstitutes ernähren sich aktuell 1,3 millionen menschen rein pflanzlich also vegan und das kommt natürlich
dem tierschutz zugute doch was viele nicht wissen auch der obst- gemüse- und getreideanbau
Ist eng mit der wirtschaft verknüpft der nährstoffe wie phosphor oder stickstoff
Werden den boden nach der ernte nicht nur in form von mist oder dummen wieder zugeführt auch
Abfallprodukte aus der tierhaltung wie blut und
Knochenmehl werden als organischer zusatz dünger eingesetzt selbst einige bio verbände erlauben das denn was viele nicht wissen die
zertifizierung vegan oder
vegetarisch bezieht sich nicht auf die produktion sondern auf das lebensmittelrecht
Das ist schon ziemlich perfide der essen wir vegane produkte dort die
ernähren sich von tierischen produkten
igitt warum gegensatz zu land
Wirtschaftsverbänden gibt es mittlerweile einige landwirte die ihre arbeit komplett wie bio vegan betreiben sie nutzen keine tiere oder
tierischen produkte und konzentrieren sich voll und ganz auf den pflanzenanbau hier reihen sich kartoffeln
salate und kohlstatt kühen und schweinen gibt es hier nur noch gemüsefelder die auch ohne tierischen dünger
aus kommen dass diese idee funktionieren kann zeigen mittlerweile rund 80
kleinbäuerlichen betriebe in griechenland die ihre produkte mittlerweile nach ganz europa exportieren acker wirtschaften und viehwirtschaft werden hier
traditionell getrennt betrieben und so wissen die bahn bereits seit generationen die landwirtschaft ohne tiere funktioniert in deutschland
wurde vor kurzem der bio
Zyklisch vegane verein gegründet wo unter anderem landwirte aus der pfalz organisiert sind die auf vegane art und weise gemüse und obst
Produzieren der verein hat sich den ausbau dieser idee in ganz deutschland auf die fahne geschrieben auf der web seite fordert er eine
kreislauf orientierte vegan
ausgerichtete form des ökologischen landbaus durch einführung der bio zyklisch veganen prinzipien in allen bereichen der land- und ernährungswirtschaft
umwelt natur und klimaschutz
tierethik gesundheit und welternährung ohne rückgriff auf die landwirtschaftliche tierhaltung haben dabei besondere bedeutung
zitat ende die albert schweitzer stiftung sieht genau dies als einen
Lösungsansatz um auf ethische art und weise einige unserer ernährungs und agra probleme, zu lösen
denn man darf nicht vergessen
für die produktion von fleisch müssen unmengen mehr an pflanzen angebaut werden als wenn wir sie direkt essen würden zurück zur bio veganen
Landwirtschaft die es in deutschland bereits vereinzelt gibt hier werden pro hof durchaus
30 bis 40 verschiedene sorten gemüse angebaut teilstücke der felder wachsen wild und bieten schutz und nahrung für nützlinge wie bienen oder
schmetterlinge so entsteht ein natürliches gleichgewicht zu dem schützen sie auf natürliche art und weise vor schäden durch mögen schnecken oder läuse auf
pestizide und künstlichen dünger dagegen wird verzichtet das einzige was an die pflanzen kommt ist bio veganer dünger wie beispielsweise kompostiert
Des klägers keine frage die pflanzen wachsen so natürlich nicht annähernd
So schnell wie die die konventionelle angebaut werden doch die meisten dieser landwirte sehen den bioanbau als einzige option die aktuelle agrarpolitik
Bezeichnen sie als verheerend für tiere verbraucher und umwelt und dieser stunde anbau ist auch
Im moment das einzige mittel gegen den dramatischen schwund an insekten über den wir hier des öfteren berichtet hatten der gefährdet nämlich die gesamte
Versorgung mit nahrungsmitteln und damit die existenz der menschheit und fest steht auch so viel fleisch wie viele von uns essen
Muss aus gesundheitlichen gründen gar nicht
sein
Im gegenteil wenn wir uns in deutschland an die empfehlung der deutschen gesellschaft für ernährung halten würden würde dies den bundesweiten
fleischkonsum um die hälfte reduzieren es gibt berechnungen nach denen dadurch fast ein viertel der
landwirtschaftlichen nutzfläche freigesetzt würde die große frage könnte man die weiter wachsende weltbevölkerung mit tier freier
landwirtschaft vegan ernähren dazu der agraringenieur daniel
mitgründer des bio vegan netzwerks in deutschland
zitat die höfe die heute schon bio vegan produzieren haben aber in hinblick auf wirtschaftlichkeit und
ressourcenverbrauch eine durchweg positive bilanz aufzuweisen die bio vegan landwirt jedenfalls sind durchweg
Optimistisch auch was den minderertrag im vergleich
zu ihrem konventionell arbeitenden kollegen angehen denn was man nicht vergessen darf die tiere sind ein zwischen glied der
nahrungskette produkte vom feld gehen in der bio vegan landwirtschaft eben nicht den umweg über das tier sondern werden direkt für die menschliche ernährung
benutzt macht auch sinn wenn man bedenkt dass bei der herstellung einer tierischen kalorie etwa 7
Pflanzliche kalorien benötigt werden und das ist an menge noch, mal mehr aber das hat man ja gerade es ist wirklich ein riesiger
energieverlust doch und bio veganen landwirtschaft weiter nach vorne zu bringen braucht es viele faktoren
zunächst einmal eine politik die entsprechende rahmenbedingungen schafft und zudem auch ein umdenken in der gesellschaft nur dann haben solche
Lösungsansatz für eine zukunftsfähige gesunde ernährung auch eine chance es ist also zeit zum handeln
Und das könnt ihr jetzt und das schreibt das generation manifest
Damit die zukunft besser wird und nicht schlechter harald lesch ist dabei melis ali
annette frier eckart von hirschhausen ich bin dabei und so weiter und so fort
Hier ist der link unbedingt mitmachen ich zähle auf euch und tier geht es weiter mit das große sterben der insekten das ist wirklich ziemlich
dramatisch und ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran